don't think that the peace conference
for nearly 25 years he was one of the
most powerful
and recognizable people in the world the
oil minister in the world's most
important oil producer
known everywhere simply as shirkhiyamani
ahmad zakiyamani became saudi arabia's
all minister
in 1962 but he became a household name
in much of the world a decade later when
he helped direct an arab world embargo
against the u.s
prompted by washington's support of
israel in the 1973 arab israeli war
could you say something about what
whether you think the price
freeze will continue oil prices
quadrupled
triggering a global recession gasoline
shortages
and even long lines at filling stations
the embargo was lifted the following
year
but it established the power of the
organization of petroleum exporting
countries or opec
over oil and shihaemani's power within
opec
a man whose every word could move global
markets
and while yemeni was known for his calm
negotiating style
he also popularized the term the oil
weapon what happens if the u.s
resorts to force and occupies the oil
fields in saudi arabia
there are some sensitive areas
in the oil fields in saudi arabia which
will be
immediately blown up by yourself
by yourself of course and then what will
happen
is europe has to live and japan of
course has to live
without oil from saudi arabia for so
many years
twice in 1975 yemeni found himself at
major moments in history
in march he was standing just outside
the room when a nephew of then king
faisal assassinated the monarch
then a few months later he was one of
several ministers taken hostage at
opec's headquarters in vienna
orchestrated by the venezuelan political
assassin known as carlos the jackal
three people were killed in that attack
he remained as minister until 1986 when
saudi arabia's king fat abruptly sacked
him
he was born in mecca in 1930 at a time
when camel still roamed the city
and lived to see his country transformed
almost beyond recognition
he oversaw the nationalization of the
arabian american oil company
better known today as aramco then and
now saudi arabia's main source of
revenue
but even at the height of his power he
knew that oil riches will
end some day the stone age didn't end
for lack of stone he said
an oil age will end long before the
world runs out of oil
zakiyamani died in london at the age of
90.